hey there folks curse waters here with a
special sponsored segment from
gamespot's III coverage here in 2016
joining me on the couch I have Roy Lou
from lion Kong interactive and Charles
young the VP of fuse games and we got
two things to talk about today gents but
for now we're just going to talk about
one you guys are mobile game developers
among other things and we're gonna talk
about independence day extinction
awesome awesome yeah King demands
de-extinction is upcoming mobile game
based on an upcoming movie the best a
resurgence movie uh yeah that's coming
out like next week around here play and
yeah it's not really looking good for
the humans in that movie the way that's
what we'll get gonna play out voice on I
didn't control the story how the movie
story goes but in our game which is
really exciting for us uh working on
that is likely the chance to play as an
alien against you and of course you're
always up you're always able to play as
a human I gave alien well ok so you got
the conflict you got the two sides human
and alien you're playing about what kind
of game is what genre are we talking
about here sure it's an action-packed
strategy game so to speak you can refer
that as too similar or something like
boom beach type of thing ok what's
different is you can well during the
battle you can always micro control your
troops your scroll around the
battlefield these are the three lips
players on top of that we got a squad
system which is card collection set them
right where you can loot the car through
every battle and it can upgrade your
squad based on whatever what you have so
you can just base like keep on upgrading
your treasures troops infantry tanks all
of that let's break it foot take a break
back a step are you building buildings
and then building units from that is it
sort of like a real time strategy game
in that it's a big battle game [ __ ]
ain't synchronized player versus player
and also has a PVE session we have all
the PVC
mind up so that it can get through a
different section on earth to fight you
know with Cuban or against alien okay so
walk me through I said you know I'm
sitting down pull out my phone I fired
up I want to play as humans what are my
goals one of my first goals when I start
to play the game save the earth just
going right for it I guess about the
aliens but how do i do it do I start
with small units and build it get bigger
yeah you start with a very basic units
but the more basically the goal is to
you save the cumin I go against alien
starting by looting their resources
starting drilling down the earth
resources like getting them back through
there ilion whatever where they're
coming from basically you get their
resources we call that titanium or
plasma whatever supposed to be used you
can't collect these resources putting
your building upgrade and Bill your
troops and keep on that loop and a fight
against aliens or in a fight against
humans exactly what are the differences
between playing as the humans and
playing as the alien Oh as a huge
difference imagine how how does how does
it feel like to be a lien just think
about that actually brings a lot of
difference actually what a cool part is
you can see from the first movie right
you saw the first ID for moon oh yeah
absolutely so and it you know its iconic
movie in a history a cipher on the
famous speech for other present what
else do you remember I remember Will
Smith punching an alien in the face what
else ah a lot of things blowing up yep
yep and and in our game this is a chance
you can leverage the super duper awesome
alien space weapon it can use that on
tier our you guys on to your enemies
exactly can you blow up any like real
earth landmarks uh not in this version
we like to keep it our upcoming packs oh
yeah the destroyer you know Tokyo pack
and then your destroy San Francisco
packet taking down the Golden Gate
Bridge yeah that's all Rome an
interesting all right get get lured lean
into that sort of disaster alien
invasion kind of
exactly actually a lot of explorers team
I would refer that as a collar with
style explosion I can experience in the
game and by using the space weapon I can
see from the movie with explosion scene
you can feel like okay it's a different
universe of overall ain't the best a
storyline all right now am I playing
against AI opponents mostly or can I
also play with other against other folks
online you can do both actually one cool
feature for our game is you could
represent your own countering for
example as a human I can fight for
United States or I can fly for for
example China apply for UK so that you
know all my Alliance who are basically
people for on UK fighting for UK and
actually in our game you can see a whole
map where you can see like okay for
example us what's the percentage of the
u.s. is dominate by alien or dominated
by humans you can see oh the gate
changes real time okay little sort of
meta game going on there exactly ah so
with mobile games like this you know you
talked about sort of earning things and
upgrading are you guys working in like
micro transactions for little boosts and
stuff like that as well right right
right we do actually we do it lightly we
do encourage people to play and enjoy
that you start off and actually we give
a lot of personally speaking I would
think this game could print your other
game on the market this game is pretty
generous any more players so that I
always taught to my designers guys you
sure about this arge that is like yeah
for sure I mean we like to but getting
games actually we put a lot of you send
for people to start doing the PvP tsecha
where I can fight you know line up with
your Alliance to humans with your nation
to fight against alien or vice versa now
line Kong is a pretty prolific mobile
game developer in China so in terms of
sort of creating games for maybe four US
market or certainly at least to go along
with the US movie release how do you
guys sort of sort of go about that how
is it a different challenge oh right
this is a big challenge to start with
that's why we have our office set up in
burlingame in the Bay Area to start off
and lucky enough we have an awesome
curve of 70 people and
in burlingame that's where we crank it
out all these kind of a like spaceship
and attacking and the stuff is there
very cool probably a lot of disaster
simulations going on in burlingame these
days huh yeah well one of the landmarks
to crack definitely a San Francisco
right yeah definitely definitely all
right Independence Day extinction coming
to mobile can you tell us sort of what
platforms and what date you're targeting
for release well as targeting summer
2016 all right both iOS and Android
great Roy thank you so much for coming
and talking a Independence Day
extinction thank you all right